Man sieht es erst, wenn ganz genau hinschaut.
Es ist unglaublich, aber wahr.
Denn dieser Bugatti Chiron ist komplett aus
Lego gebaut.
Der Original-Sportwagen kostet rund 2,4 Millionen
Euro.
Dieses Gefährt hingegen besteht aus etwa
einer Millionen Legosteinen.
Hinter der Aktion steckt das Designteam von
Lego Technic.
Auf der Lego-Webseite wird berichtet, dass
die Idee dem Team gekommen sei, als sie am
Lego-Bausatz des Chiron im Maßstab 1:8 arbeiteten.
16 Personen investierten daraufhin etwa 13.400
Arbeitsstunden.
Doch während das Original eine Geschwindigkeit
von rund 400 km/h erreicht, muss sich das
Lego-Fahrzeug auf einer Teststrecke in Wolfsburg
mit etwa 20 km/h zufrieden geben.
Aber immerhin: er fährt.